So let's take a look, is this statement
correct? No, because here we're passing the userId,
and that's not correct. We have to pass
the key of the ancestor. So here, is this
code correct? We are passing the userKey, so
that's right, but, oh, something's missing here, it
needs to be conference.class not just conference. And
here, this is right. We're loading type Conference.class, and
we're passing the ancestor key. Correct. And
over here in the conferenceapi.java file, have a
quick look at the definition for getConferencesCreated. Again,
we annotate it as @ApiMethod,. Specify the name,
the path, and the HTTPMethod post. So this time because we need the user to
be locked in, we do pass the user
argument and we have to throw an UnauthorizedException
in case that user is not logged in. So here's the code, should be very familiar
by now. For throwing the exception if the
user's not logged in. We get the user ID,
getUserId, we get the key of the user from their ID,
because remember, we use the userId to generate the key and here we do the
query. We load ofy.load.type Conference.class, specify the userKey
as the ancestor. To order by name, and then
finally, we execute the list to actually run the
query. After you deploy your app to localhost, you
can test it in the API's explorer. So here's the
conference API. Here you see the getConferencesCreated method that
you just defined. You are going to need to make
sure that you refresh your browser, or you won't
see it. Drill down into it, I'm going to execute it.
Oh look, forgot to authorize maps because we required the user argument. If
I authorize, now I'll try again, and here I
see in the response, the conferences that I've created.
So the UI calls the same function. It calls
the getConferencesCreated. You could also use the Conferences Created
page in the UI. Because when you go to
that tab, it actually calls the same method that
you've just created. You can use whichever you prefer,
the tab in the UI or the API's explorer,
to check that the function works.